So back in the day,
I would never have been able to afford a SAA flights,
but now that they've come back,
it's actually quite affordable.
So come with me and we'll see how it goes.
This is really awkward.
So apart from the fact that it took us some time to actually board,
I was super excited
because my new Takealot backpack actually fit under the seat.
Hashtag winning at laugh. I had an entire row to myself
and I even took a video of this random person's knees
so that you can see the leg space of the aircraft.
You're welcome. Now,
we did deal with a little bit of turbulence,
but as you can see, I wasn't scared at all.
Also, in case you didn't know,
when you fly SAA, you get a free meal and a drink during the flight.
And this had me like a kid before Christmas. Testing, testing.
Oh no, she's coming back.
That's fine. Thank you. Enjoy.
We had a freaking delicious chicken and cheese bun and a drink.
I asked for tea. Um,
is it possible to have some tea?
And the hostess gave me tea and bottled water. Score.
The only downside was that they ran out of the vegetarian option,
which if I was a vegetarian,
I would have been bombed. I'm not gonna lie.
Overall though, I really enjoy the friendly stuff
in the comfortable flight to Cape Town
where I'll be spending the coming week exploring the Overberg. Area,
just in case you missed it,
that was the full shadowing of the post that will be coming this week.